-Welcome back.
We're hanging out with
Eddie Redmayne.
Now, Eddie, you play
Newt Scamander
in the
"Fantastic Beasts" movies.
So we thought we'd put
your knowledge of the character
to the test in a game called
"Know Your Role."
Here we go. Okay, here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Know your role ♪
-Now, here's how it works.
I'm going to give you an obscure
fact about your character
or the wizarding world --
universe in general.
And you have to tell me
if you think
that statement is true or false.
It might get a little tricky,
'cause your character has
a pretty wild backstory.
Are you ready for this?
-I am. Go for it.
-Okay.
-Hit me.
-American wiz--
And you guys can help.
Or maybe not.
Up to you, up to you.
American wizards use --
American wizards use currency
known as dragots and sprinks.
[ Audience shouting "False!" ]
-Oh, guys, you are so helpful.
Thank you. False.
-That is true, actually.
[ Buzzer ]
I sold that.
I sold sprinks funny on purpose.
-But it was such confidence
from the audience.
-I know, I know.
I was like, "Sprinks."
Yeah, I hit that,
but that was --
Yeah, that actually is true.
Dragots and sprinks --
American wizards.
There you go.
-Perfect.
-Your character, Newt Scamander,
once had a relationship with
a hippogriff named Buckbeak.
-A relationship?
That's all kinds of dodgy.
-Yeah, a relationship.
It could be platonic.
-Well, I remember Newt's mom
bred and raised hippogriffs.
So I'm going to go with true.
-False. We know...
[ Buzzer ]
So far, you're doing great.
-That's, like,
a really cruel audience.
-No, they're doing --
They're playing with us.
It's really good. I love this.
Thank you, guys.
I love this.
Alright, a new word
was created for
the "Fantastic Beasts" movie,
shriekelnoir,
which is a magical ability to
change size to fit
into small spaces.
-No, and I love that
I know this,
because there was a word
called choranaptyxic.
-That's correct.
[ Buzzer ]
That is correct.
That's not a buzzer.
That's a correct.
[ Ding ]
Yeah, that's --
That is exactly right.
-Thank you.
-How do you pronounce it?
-Choranaptyxic. But I love that
you just told me
that it was invented, because
I thought it was a real word.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It was invented.
Yeah, just for you.
Alright, here we go.
Newt was expelled from Hogwarts
for using a spell
that turned his professor's
hands into crab claws.
-Newt was expelled from
Hogwarts,
but as far as I'm aware, not for
my sort of "Karate Kid" dance.
-That is correct. It's false.
Yeah, that is correct.
Yes, you're right.
He was not expelled for
that reason, no.
Newt Scamander's
middle name is Fido.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Yeah, it is true. Yeah.
[ Ding ]
-Fido Artemis.
I like that.
Newt is actually able to
temporarily transform himself
into a fantastic beast
known as snardvark.
-I'm desperate for it to be yes.
But -- Can we suggest that for
"Fantastic Beasts 4?"
-Yeah, yeah. You're correct.
-But the great thing about these
movie is that they're magic.
You can do anything.
-It's all magic. It's all magic.
Alright, this is good.
You're doing great.
You're back. You're back.
-Thanks, man. Back in the room.
-Here we go.
Which of the following beasts is
not featured in Newt's book?
Glumbumble, nogtail, niffler,
gugengoggle...
chizpurfle.
-You know, I think
the cameraman is laughing.
-I don't know which one
he's laughing at, but yeah.
-The gugengoggle.
-That is correct.
Gugengoggle is not true.
This guy know his stuff!
You know your role.
Eddie Redmayne, everybody!
Check out "Fantastic Beasts:
The Secrets of Dumbledore" --
in theaters April 15th.